what I took from Kilimanjaro I learned
the power of my story I'm not trying to
be an inspiration what I try to do is be
an example of like if this is what I can
do what can we all do
[Music]
my name is Spencer West I'm a
motivational speaker and an author I was
born with a genetic disease that
basically caused the muscles in my legs
not to work I had two surgeries the
first one was at the age of two where
they were gonna remove my legs at the
knee the hope was I would use prosthetic
legs to get around that way but it
didn't work then at the age of five they
were removed just below my pelvis so I
could get around better after my
surgeries my parents met with the
doctors and they basically told my
parents I would probably never walk by
myself sit up by myself or be a
functioning member of society I grew up
in a small town called Rock Springs in
the state of Wyoming everyone on our
block we all knew each other we all
played together and what was so
interesting is that they treated me just
like everybody else they like a rode a
skateboard with folks in my neighborhood
I felt like I belonged but it was when I
started school that things started to
change at recess I didn't want to play
sports with the boys so like I was
always playing house with the girls and
like hanging out with them because of
that you know I was called a [ __ ] I
was called queer I was called gay and
auntie's for always hanging out with the
girls and that was really hard because I
was starting to have an idea that maybe
I was gay as well and then when
something like that happens you're
terrified and you don't want to be that
anymore and so you pretend not to be my
first real career was working at a salon
and spa this was an incredible job and I
made some amazing friends there and I
really enjoyed the people that I worked
with but the job didn't fulfill what I
was looking for I didn't feel like I had
a purpose there other than just to make
money
in March of 2008 I went to Kenya with my
friend Reed and his partner Greg and I
saw the work that this organization we
was doing and I remember flying back to
Nairobi we were coming from the Masai
Mara
I was asking you know what would it take
to work for the organization my
facilitator said oh you'd have to move
to Toronto and I said oh okay
after a couple of years at we I'm
speaking all across the world now and
I'm working with students and I'm
working with other people telling that
listen you need to make a difference you
need to create awareness you need to
create a campaign that will either raise
funds or raise awareness about the
things that you care about specifically
I was traveling with her founder Craig
Kielburger and he had just nonchalantly
been like hey have you ever thought
about climbing Kilimanjaro and I was
like no what and a week later I thought
wow
maybe I could I can show you that like
I'm gonna do exactly what I tell them to
do and so I thought about it for a week
and I went back to Craig and I said yes
I want to do this but this is what I
want to do I want to create a campaign
and he basically said go do it I went to
my two buddies their names are David and
Alex and I was like I can't do this by
myself and what if we like have this
really cool adventure as friends we
named our campaign redefined possible
and initially we wanted to raise money
to build schools then that summer East
Africa got hit with one of the largest
droughts they'd seen in over 60 years so
we decided to do clean water instead got
a personal trainer we trained really
hard a lot of people were super excited
and couldn't wait to get involved my
poor mother what's like so terrified and
this is like her worst nightmare I'm
like someone that pushes the limits a
lot for myself but I kept thinking maybe
this is like too far that first day we
definitely panicked a little bit because
it was so much harder than we thought we
had trained that I would do 50% of my
hands and 50% of my wheelchair I knew
for sure that I liked I couldn't do the
whole mountain on my hands your arms are
not meant to be walked on like that so
that was the hope that though I was
gonna do half and half that wasn't
accurate it worked for a little bit and
then we got to the actual part where the
trail started and my wheelchair was too
wide so that okay this first Stacia
I can get out and I can walk a little
bit and then I can rest then I can walk
a little bit and that's what we did but
very quickly we started to realize that
this is how it was going to be there
wasn't a lot of options for me to use my
chair so I either needed to really give
in and walk half the day and then have
my friends carry me or if there were
places I could use my wheelchair they
could push me which I wasn't prepared
for I wanted to do more than that the
other thing that was really hard is that
I had to give up my independence and as
someone with a disability you spend your
entire life fighting for independence
and that was hard and in those moments
there's nothing that you can do but just
accept it the morning of summit it's
dark outside all you can see is this
beautiful blanket of stars it's so cold
it like our water in our water bottles
had head froze
Kilimanjaro isn't a technical climb it's
just weather the altitude affects you
were not the first half
I needed my friends and they were
amazing it physically and emotionally
supporting me and then
the roles reversed and my buddies got
altitude sickness and I didn't I just I
didn't if there's no rhyme or reason
there's no explanation I always make a
joke that it's because I'm so short at
that point they were like it is far too
steep for you to walk on your hands and
for us like carry you in this
contraption and so they tied me in a
blanket on the porters back and
literally carried me that way and I'll
never forget as we were zigzagging we
literally watched night turn in today on
one side it was still dark as the Sun
came up on the other side we finally got
to the point where it's like the last
part before you start walking towards
the top called Gilman's point
Kilimanjaro is a volcano and an active
volcano and so you can see now we have
to walk around the rim which then leads
to the highest point the boys had
prepared some videos for me because they
knew we would need something for this
last push so we had a video from my
family we all just started to walk
together and that's when my other
friends started to get sick
I wasn't feeling altitude sickness but
you feel the altitude every motion takes
all of your efforts if I were just like
jump out of this chair here would be no
problem but on Kilimanjaro if you did
that it would take you a minute to catch
your breath now both of my friends were
so sick that they were throwing up
something as simple as your foot
slipping a little bit on the ice my
friend Alex just would crumble like to
his knees the porters had started to
carry me again because it was too
dangerous for me to walk along the rim
in some spots and then we got to one
point where we could rest again and I
just said you need to put me down
because my buddies were so sick I felt
so guilty I thought I was the one that
was gonna need help and now here they
were suffering because I asked them to
come and I asked him to support me and
now the roles are reversed and they
needed my help the entire climb they
kept saying you know what it's really
inspiring to watch you walk up this
mountain I was like f blah blah but the
minute we stopped I thought what else
can I do honestly it was the first day
ever in my entire life where I wanted
legs that day so I could like carry my
friends like they had carried me and so
what kept playing over in my head is it
so inspiring to watch you walk my
parents have always taught me to focus
on the things that I could do so I
thought well this is all that I know to
do so we literally stood together and I
stood in between them and I said we're
just gonna walk hand over hand and foot
of her foot and as slow as we need to we
walked a little bit more for an Alex
puked walked a little bit more crumbled
picked him up walked a little bit more
and we could see it just
off in the distance there it was there
it was and slowly we just kept walking
and stopping and walking and stopping
and eventually we we made it to the
summit it felt like slow motion we
slowly got there and we just collapsed
into each other's arms and just cried
but it was bittersweet
we like hugged we like took a minute to
just like be in the moment I went to
Kenya to facilitate one of our youth
trips and I remember I got there and my
body just gave out and I got the flu and
I was like out of commission for two
days I remember laying in that tent and
having separation anxiety within you
know a day of each other we got message
each other more like we really miss you
and we all miss each other that's when
it hit me
Wow we did that we did that we made it
to the top and we showed the world that
anything is possible
[Music]
I really want people to recognize is
that we all have the ability and the
responsibility to give back and it looks
different for every person
[Music]